ah oui
harry
moi
e
un ami lui samedi soir bienvenue sur le
plateau de cette spéciale mayans poiret
et grands moments vous ne connaissez pas
le principe mais vous connaissez
l'équipe
voici bien balle made
alors qu'hier en feuilletant la presse
de ces derniers temps vous vous êtes
rendu compte que pour l'anniversaire des
dix ans de la disparition de jacqueline
maillan et jean poiret aucun hommage
était prévu et bah oui on leur de
messages croix ouais alors donné ça et
je t'ai demandé merci de l'avoir fait
alors ils ont fait tellement rire qu'on
va qu'on va ici sinon regardez les fait
rire mais aussi c'est difficile
d'évoquer des gens qui nous ont fait
rire
ben la mort des gens drôles et un petit
peu plus inacceptable que celle des
autres
je trouve pour rendre hommage à
jacqueline maillan et à jean poiret bien
entendu nous reverrons leur grand moment
au théâtre au cabaret à la télévision au
cinéma
nous recevrons des témoins de leur
carrière michel roux roger carel mais
aussi nous leur rendrons hommage en nous
amusant comme comme des grands enfants
que nous sommes finalement et pour sa
j'accueille muriel robin
venez en bas c'est que jamais
attablés
et bien sûr le maintien
le
voilà amphibie télévision dit promotion
et on passe avant toute chose comme
d'habitude la télévision à la promotion
leur miel urbain à vous sortez à un
disque de musique plus ou moins connues
que vous interprétez à la cithare jeu
s'arrête par les guitares c'est un
instrument finalement très peu connu
ouais et j'avais envie de le faire
découvrir au public
et comme je rejoue très bien qu'on ne
sais pas je me suis dit fais voilà
c'était pas bête de faire un album et
c'est vous qui jouez sur tous les bancs
de l'école morceau 126 mais alors il
chose que sait on en parle peu de la
cithare et moi j'aime bien bien
peaufiner le dossier
on peut tout jouer classique à 1 c'est à
dire que je veux bien dire aux gens que
ça va de sa vallée des roses blanches à
hesmond où vivent en présent par
roultaboul ma poule
parce que la jupette en bas la macarena
là il ya une particularité muriel aussi
qu'il ya quelques jours michel maes est
étonnant c'est très très suis la seule à
le faire dans le monde
ouais on a envie d'ailleurs avec l'autre
main vous faites un gommage fait des
crêpes
donna une rythmique guie guie guie alors
moi je vais pas vous raconter
d'histoires je pense pas écoutez je j'ai
reçu le disque à un mois et demi donc
j'ai pas encore le temps de tout écouter
mais je suis extrêmement extrêmement
impressionné par votre talent de
sitariste et je crois qu'on peut dire
aussi à nos amis téléspectateurs que les
bénéfices vont dans ma tâche à dormir
alors là c'est un livre très étonnant
qui s'appelle la pâte jaune alors
quelqu'un est passée la page on en fait
c'est tout simple c'est un ouvrage d'une
page dans lequel j'ai relevé en fait les
meilleurs numéros des dfa john ont fait
les gens sérieux
une idée que d'une manière générale
ouvrage les pages jaunes étaient
beaucoup plus beaucoup trop volumineux
enfin c'est vrai qu'il est beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de personnages ça
commence bien piètre on se perd dans des
trucs c'est vrai qu'ils avaient du bon
mais il y avait aussi du moins bon donc
je je je sais que c'est évidemment très
subjectif mais je pense que dans la page
jaune il ya vraiment le meilleur d'eux
les pages jaunes mais y'a quoi par
exemple je peux vous lire je peux vous
lire au hasard bon ben voilà four à pain
du cône au 74 rue dupetit-thouars 115
008 paris 01 42 45 27 26
il ya d'autres mineurs oui oui bah là je
sais pas
et alors par exemple matériel de piscine
établissements bombard 11 rue de la
pompe
01 43 00 01 09
dalmat un autre un petit dernier parce
que bon je crois qu'il faut pas tout
lire sont laissés un peu la surprise au
secteur il ya sûrement préféré moi et
c'est chez moune corbeil en latex de
place dauphine sont de 15 03 48 88 06
authentique
ces logos spectateurs un ça va la fin je
chose en soi quand vous vous êtes ici
surtout pour une cassette vidéo et un
dvd qui s'appelle une nuit avec moi oui
je suis en tous sens pu dévoiler si je
vous donnais comme ça 30 secondes pour
vendre votre produit en regardant votre
gamin c'est une
c'est une cassette où on va dormir
pendant toute une nuit et vont la garder
les meilleurs moments c'est à dire deux
heures mais bon le concept c'est ce à
quoi on voulait pas ennuyer les gens
concept c'est ça c'est moi la meilleure
ouais ben aguida il faut dire que c'est
quand même de deux heures d'émotion pure
parce qu'on doit dormir dans tous les
sens si j'ose dire c'est à dire un petit
peu sur le côté sur le dos la bouche
ouverte
à un moment je ronfle comme partiel par
mois et ça c'est bien
bon voilà donc
je veux dire que j'ai dormir pendant
tout le film et que bon ben voilà ça
sent quand même dans la cassette alors
ça a été tourné dans ma chambre dans mon
lit d'ailleurs peut-être des gens
reconnaîtront je le dis comme ça avec de
gros moyens ainsi qu'à mes instants de
son dolby stéréo quand même comment
l'idée m'est venue nuit où dormait pas
et je me disais oh là là je suis bien
envie de dormir qu'est ce que ça me
ferait du bien dormir et je me suis dit
d'un seul coup ma tantie moi ça me fait
du bien dormir je me vois pourquoi tout
le monde serait pas content de me voir
dormir voilà c'est aussi bête que ça
c'est pas plus intelligent que la
sodomie la descente à esi cordelle
et élan mais serait-ce que la muette
s'est excusé moi exclusif est-ce que sur
le dvd il ya des bonus parce que fin
vous a vu chantal lauby dormir je sais
pas si je n'ai pas vu encore messieurs
enchaîne fusil on peut dire un moment
donné je mets la donne mais ça c'est du
bonus ma position chan physique je
voulais dire quand est ce que de temps
en temps il ya des moments où vous
faites
oui bah et a même un moment où je bave
dans la fin c'est vers la fin
alors laurent vous êtes ici pour un très
bel ouvrage près du passé pierre s'il
vous plaît monsieur on his appelle des
bêtes et basse
il vient de sortir c'est un album photo
alors est ce un homme je caresse des
animaux dont je réussi à mêler de deux
passions qui sont les caresses et les
animaux oui bon ça peut paraître un peu
comme sa linea mais basculement parce
qu'après il ya une diversité dans les
espèces animales qui est foudroyante un
coup à gauche caresse à l'éléphant la
gauche caresse un zèbre un coup je je
caresse bon image d'elle même c'est
quand même c'est troublant assez bossé
et voilà c'est toute une vie de caresses
avec des animaux je pense que le public
attendait cet ouvrage et les vélivoles
l'avoir mondiale animaux
écoutez si je compte ma femme j'en ai
caressé 123 mais il a fallu choisir pour
l'album donc il y en a que 82 dans
l'album est votre meilleur souvenir de
caresses pendant les prises de vues du
livre s'est passé un truc un jour où je
cassais une taupe art il tourne et non
c'est vrai c'est parce que c'est ce que
c'est l'avis des rencontres et et ça a
été assez fort assez fort oui il ya un
autre ouvrage en préparation laurent oui
un autre ouvrage en préparation où je me
caresserait pendant 200 pages et là tu
as juste retour des choses je demanderai
des animaux que les cages et sa valise
et de me prendre en photo et le système
de déclencheur maintenant je peux pas
dire encore lesquels parce que bon
certains ce sont son contrat tout non
tous sont pas acceptés entre ailleurs à
la taupe dont je parle et ça donne envie
non
devon livre
alors la promo on va passer à jacqueline
maillan ya maintenant ah c'est vrai oui
non may hamm a pour moi je dis pas que
j'ai une promo bat g de l'actualité
belle par exemple j'ai une tournée que
je fais à l'entraînement la maj de
varian a poussé l'hommage à palmade 70
peu limite dans une émission qui est un
hommage de parler de sa tournée de sa
promo cdg au fond c'est des oeuvres
assez pour tout le monde
mais tous de tous secteurs non attends
je perdais sur moi je te connais bien
au set ça me déçoit père moi je trouve
que c'est vrai que ça manque quand même
un qe2 et bombarde de faire un hommage a
pas de malades on va faire même un jeu
de mata va pas trop bien voilà